two stories popped up in the last couple
days that I thought were really
interesting so first off the feds right
now are seeking prison time for a 70
year old medical marijuana patient who
was growing weed on his personal
property in washington the state of
Washington where medical marijuana is
legal they also fat they found about 70
poplin they also did find some guns but
he wasn't doing anything illegal per se
by the state laws but again this is the
feds that stepped in and did this
because medical marijuana is obviously
not legal at the federal level and I
think this is really interesting because
to me I want to start with Obama here
because I think he's had this both ways
he makes it seem like he's the cool hip
weed-smoking president right and he
talks about weed all time and even said
about two months ago the thing about you
know we'd is no worse than you know
having a couple drinks or something yet
he is in charge of the federal
government if I know anything about
government and he is the one that is
still enforcing these laws that are
allowing the feds to come in and close
these places to Obama I start with start
with Obama and then we'll go back so so
obviously as president he can't
personally go through every bit of the
government and make sure that they're
doing what he tells them to I find this
very surprising because Eric Holder the
Attorney General yeah put out a guidance
uh what was it six months ago a year ago
saying that we are not going to focus on
individual users we're not going to
focus on you know the nonviolent
offenders we're going to focus on people
who are obviously involved in crime and
drug trafficking these people obviously
not involved in that so i think that
there's an issue right with the this is
equate the US attorney in Washington
State right so this is a hundred percent
against what Eric Holder said by the way
the guy who did this the seven-year-old
medical marijuana patient is facing ten
years in prison as are some of his
relatives that lived on the comment and
a family friend um so is this just like
the worst kind of government hypocrisy
oh well you know i love the government
so much I'm good to you know totally
agree with you there no um first of all
the ten years is not I don't think it's
normal they're added years because he
was found to be in accession of firearms
right so you know I don't know if this
is a typical situation I do think this
is one of those things where as as
things change
and as you know the sovereignty of
states are recognized by the federal
government let's hope that that as you
know nationwide mentality towards this
changes and it looks like it's going in
that direction especially for somebody
who's just doing it for medicinal
purposes for providing for people who
have seizures epilepsy of cancer yeah I
think that we naturally it'll change
this it's just that weird space before
we get to where we're going yeah so the
medicinal part I want to get to in a
second but what is the angle here I
really like this is one of those things
where Obama says one thing it does how I
can't I just can't figure out what is
his what is the point what is he saying
to hold her what that they feel this is
appropriate I think it I think this is a
conflict between a US Attorney and that
is actually defying orders from the the
main office essentially I you know I
don't get the impression that Obama or
holder think that this is a wise use of
resources right so why does it hold her
just get on the phone I don't know that
I don't understand because you know he
could get on and say you need to stop
doing this this is a waste of resources
they're going after you know a 70 year
old man who owned guns which is you know
his right under the Second Amendment
yeah because they were saying that he
was using those guns in the commission
of a crime because federally having pot
you know growing weed on your property
is against the law even though it is not
against the law in the state right it
shouldn't be those things are not even
on the same plane but they are in
conflict and there is a huge gray area
of legal limbo so we know for the US
attorney to then sort of defy I think
there's something else going on with
this particular US attorney but I do not
know what that is because really it's
completely illogical for him to be doing
what he's doing yeah all right so we'll
get to the medicinal part in a sec but
shouldn't the Republicans to me this
seems like the type of thing where if
they were smart which they're not and we
know that if they were smart they'd be
like this is the type of thing we should
be fighting more because it's fighting
for states rights it's fighting for
individual liberty you get a lot of
sympathy saying I want someone who is
sick to be able to do whatever it takes
to feel better why don't they jump on
board this thing I think it would
alienate so much of their base as far as
the people who are of the generation who
grew up with like those crazy videos and
60s of kids like smoking weed and ended
up in my flophouses yeah right um I
think that's the only reason but I agree
with you I mean look this is an
opportunity for you to like be on the
cutting edge of of like the future so
why would you break it but and they
could be taken they could be taking a
populist thing and saying look what
Obama's doing that's why i don't get the
Obama angle and I don't get the the
Republican angle and I think it like I
think you're right i think it has to do
with the preconceived notions from the
base from you know the older generations
who are less likely to be open to the
idea of medical marijuana or even
recreational marijuana although but
let's be real like my parents I'm sure
smoked way more weed than I ever yeah
well that didn't go to comments i did
good god you're right you're right that
you know when you don't go to school the
drugs are just part you can't find them
exactly there